Ніна Хрущова, онука радянського лідера Микити Хрущова написала книгу про свого дідуся,
і ця книга, ймовірно, вийде в Росії з цензурними скороченнями.
Програма "В тренді" спілкувалася з Ніною Хрущовою у Вільнюсі.
І вона розповіла нам про те, як саме її дід передавав Крим Україні,
чи існує, на її думку, у Росії запит на новий режим "твердої руки"
і чому Путін був, є і буде в очах американців голлівудським лиходієм?
Ніно Хрущова, ласкаво просимо до програми "В тренді" на Deutsche Welle.
Доброго дня. Дуже дякую.
Одразу хотів би почати з відносно недавнього епізоду з вашого життя.
У день заколоту Пригожина ви поїхали до Кремля і дивилися,
як там виставляють протитанкові загородження, чи концентруються війська.
Як ви оцінюєте цю подію, і все, що відбулося потім?
Це був удар по путінському режиму чи ні?
І так, і ні. Я пішла пішки.
Я, слава Богу, живу досить близько і просто дивилася з віддалених околиць Кремля на близькі околиці Кремля.
Було дуже цікаво, бо що ближче наближаєшся до Кремля,
тим більше відчуваєш, що байдужість народу зашкалює.
Мене всі переконували, всі, з ким я розмовляла дорогою,
що це все скінчиться чудово, і взагалі Пригожин нам не загроза, Путін нас захистить.
Одна жінка сказала мені… Я кажу: ну, а там вже начебто є кадри, як люди на танк залазять.
А вона каже: це Голлівуд, кому це все цікаво?
Я кажу: а ви що думаєте?
Вона каже: незважаючи на патріотичне виховання, я не шанувальниця Путіна, - так сказала ця жінка, -
бо він уже занадто довго сидить.
Так-то все добре, але сидить довго.
Малося на увазі - в Кремлі.
І вона каже: мій хлопчик - там бігав хлопчик приблизно семирічного віку -
ходитиме до школи все-таки, незважаючи на всю цю піонерію,
а так він буде дитячим солдатом у пригожинській армії.
На цьому, мені здавалося, теж грає Кремль.
Тобто як б ви до нас не ставилися, все одно ми кращі,
ніж як кажуть, англійською better then the alternativе…
Кращі за альтернативу.
Так, головна фраза Джо Байдена: "Не порівнюйте мене із Богом, порівняйте мене з альтернативою".
І у Путіна - "порівняйте мене з альтернативою".
Навіть мої колеги в Америці казали: як Путін дозволив дійти?
Я думаю, що це насправді було абсолютно навмисне.
Було зрозуміло, що коли він зовсім підійде…
Тобто ми добрі, ми не хочемо вас втопити в крові, тому що втопимо, якщо захочемо.
Звісно, дозволяємо страшні речі, вбивства в процесі цього всього.
Але як ви знаєте, ціна російського життя, власне, і на боці держави, і не на боці держави, нічого не варта.
Але коли він підійшов до Москви, далі ультиматум: чи так, чи все.
І в цьому сенсі, я це відразу теж говорила, що все-таки,
знаєте, якщо ви цілитеся в короля, ви повинні його вбити;
якщо ви не вбиваєте короля, то король переміг.
Він переміг, і це його посилило.
Я пам'ятаю, ми це обговорювали з різними іноземними колегами, мовляв, ось він зараз...
Він зараз ослаб. Він загалом слабкий.
Це не питання, що він сильний, але в його слабкості,
оскільки немає альтернативи, він прибрав усю альтернативу,
неможливо уявити собі, як це буде інакше...
Коли тобі на Заході кажуть: усю Росію треба перемогти.
Покажіть мені країну, яка хоче бути переможеною.
Тобто це все йому допомагає.
А далі, як ви знаєте, випадково у Пригожина в тілі опинилися раптом граната та наркотики.
Тут далі ми можемо говорити або про дуже довгий шлях Путіна,
або про дуже короткий, але передбачати, що завтра це все від слабкості розвалиться
- це як звичайна російська формула, тобто "якось та й тримається",
тобто у тебе бандаж з одного боку, розламана стіна підпирає іншу, але начебто вежа тримається.
Може розвалитися, а може ще 10 років протриматися.
Дуже часто тепер особливо на Заході, а також в російських опозиційних колах кажуть:
це станеться тоді, коли Путін програє війну в Україні,
коли йому там буде завдано дуже значної поразки.
Дуже коротко: ви згодні з цим?
Знову ж таки: і згодна, і ні.
Бо я не уявляю, як Путін може програти війну в Україні.
Я просто не уявляю цього.
Як територія на 11 часових поясах може програти?
Росія може програти, якщо її окупують.
А як її можна окупувати?
Навіть якщо вони зазнають певних поразок,
це все одно ніколи не буде поразка, про яку ми думаємо, коли говоримо про поразку.
Це не Німеччина 1945-го року.
Окупувати не можна, а якщо не можна окупувати,
значить - не можна перемогти в тому сенсі, коли кажуть про геостратегічну поразку.
Навіть якщо голову цього дракона відрізати,
хвіст все одно залишиться і продовжуватиме лежати й гнити.
Як закінчиться путінський режим, на вашу думку?
Тому що останнім часом є такі розмови:
або варіант, близький до вашої сімейної історії, смерть Сталіна в 1953-му,
але для цього Путін повинен померти, якось зійти зі сцени.
Або це 1964-ий, коли відбулося повалення вашого діда.
Які є варіанти, на вашу думку?
Знову, вибачте, і те, і інше.
Я розумію, що Путін може померти.
Так.
Тоді буде якесь з'ясування стосунків, боротьба за владу.
А 1964-ий рік - це можливо?
Цілком можливо. По-перше, в Росії можливо все.
Ось ця вежа, яка тримається з одного боку на бандажі, з іншого боку - зламана стіна,
і все одно вона стоїть, але вона може впасти будь-якої миті.
Смерть Сталіна була несподіваною, хоча цього можна було очікувати.
Навіть 64-й рік стався несподівано,
хоча Хрущова, як я тепер дізналася в процесі написання книги про нього,
що його попереджали щонайменше п'ять разів.
За 5 разів взагалі можна було зрозуміти, що це з тобою станеться?
Може, звісно, і, чесно кажучи, мене здивувало, що це не сталося на початку,
тому що ми бачили, що вся його, як-то кажуть, еліта, була в шоці, у них щелепи повідвисали.
Там кожен реагував, у Матвієнка була істерика.
У Наришкіна був серцевий напад, тощо.
Після початку повномасштабного вторгнення.
Так, 24-го було відчуття, що ось зараз…
І коли потім, коли здали Херсон рік тому.
Коли прийняли до складу РФ ці чотири утворення, чи як ми там їх називаємо.
Усі мовчали, усі виконували накази, але водночас було видно,
що всі хочуть, аби це скоріше закінчилося.
Я думаю, що проблема в тому, що, по-перше, на Заході весь час обіцяють,
що їх підвішуватимуть за ноги та всі інші місця, коли це все закінчиться,
тобто вони обирають менше для себе страждання.
Потім, знову ж таки, коли всі кажуть, що вас треба знищити, то цього не хочеться.
Що робити? Ми зараз бачимо, що Фрідман поїхав з Лондона, у нього це не вийшло.
Збирається частіше приїжджати до Москви і так далі.
Треба до речі сказати, що і тоді, в 1964 році, усунення Хрущова замислювалося за рік до того.
Але Леонід Брежнєв страшенно боявся: а раптом Хрущов дізнається, тоді він нас усіх уб'є.
А Хрущов вже дізнався і все одно нікого не вбив.
Це така собі банка з павуками.
Але тоді була комуністична банка з павуками, яка в порівнянні з КГБ-істською банкою з павуками
взагалі ніщо. Це просто рай, у якому і змія, і Адам, і Єва живуть у цілковитому мирі й любові.
А чим конкретно відрізняється сьогоднішня банка з павуками?
На вашу думку, в чому її головна відмінність від радянської?
На Заході і серед російських критиків режиму часто лунає думка,
що Путін повертає Росію до Радянського Союзу.
Розкажіть по цьому пункту, буквально дуже коротко,
у чому відмінність радянської банки з павуками від нинішньої банки з павуками?
По-перше, я не думаю, що Путін повертається до Радянського Союзу.
Вікторія Нуланд любить цю ідею, вона Радянським Союзом займалася.
Путін створює путінізм, він створює свою путінську Росію.
Тому що радянська влада - це коротко, а він себе бачить на теренах історії від початку і до самого кінця.
І це, на мій погляд, важливо розуміти, тому що це не тільки ось цей відрізок.
Хоча він діє ленінськими методами.
Ленін хотів революцію - зараз ми перебудуємо світ,
і Путін збудує нам новий тощо.
Тобто елементи є, але елементи всіх тоталітарних систем насправді не такі вже й різні.
Це знаєте, якщо я можу так сказати, це може бути не дуже ввічливо, але зрозуміло:
це як порнографія, у ній є тільки кілька рухів, інакше не придумаєш, просто іншого немає.
І це схоже все, безумовно.
Але банка з павуками… Мене весь час запитують, а що б Хрущов сказав?
Я кажу: Хрущов би сказав "Ви хотіли КГБ-іста, ви його отримали".
Ви кажете, що це КГБ-істська банка з павуками, а не путінська.
Це що означає?
Що якщо Путін завтра вмирає, то залишаться ті самі КГБ-істи при владі й нічого не зміниться?
Можливо, залишаться, я не знаю, я не Кассандра, не ворожка.
Але це і путінська банка з павуками, тому що КГБ-істська банка з павуками -
скажімо, генерал КГБ, як його звати… Сергій Іванов, чи навіть Патрушев. Це одне.
А майор КГБ у цій банці з павуками - це зовсім інше.
При чому майор КГБ невисокого зросту, який каже, що він вищий, ніж він є насправді.
Тобто він, щоправда, підполковник, але він все одно майор,
бо це його справжній чин, підполковника йому дали, коли він ішов з цієї організації.
І це така ще банка з павуками, у якій павуки маленькі,
але хочуть зробити вигляд, що вони дуже великі.
Показати генералам на кшталт Іванова, Патрушева і так далі, що він, між іншим, теж генерал.
Ось ви б в Україну не пішли, а я ось зараз тут усім покажу чергову "кузькіну мать 2022".
І в цьому, на мій погляд, теж велика різниця.
Наступний рік - рік виборів.
Дуже дивна історія, коли двоє людей дуже поважного віку - головні претенденти на президентське крісло у США.
Як це може позначитися на російсько-американських відносинах?
І на тому, що у найближчий рік робитиметься чи не робитиметься щодо путінської Росії та агресії проти України?
Байден на сьогоднішній момент, як ми бачимо принаймні зараз, наразі свій потенціал щодо України вичерпав,
бо бюджет ухвалили без допомоги Україні.
Зараз ідуть розмови про те, чи це можливо, чи неможливо і таке інше.
Поки Конгрес, республіканці, чинять йому спротив.
Тобто наскільки Байден протягом року, який йому лишився,
зможе й надалі виступати за Україну і отримувати підтримку більшості - це питання.
Тепер він буде зайнятий. Тепер усі зайняті Ізраїлем.
Навіть Володимир Зеленський, президент України, сказав,
що це, можливо, буде проблема, якщо увага відвернеться.
Далі розпочинаються передвиборчі перегони.
Ми бачили, ми знаємо американські передвиборчі гонки - це просто…
Якщо цирк - це цирк, то це просто цирк у кубі, у квадраті, в чому завгодно.
А головне, що Байден балотуватиметься проти Трампа, це те, що ви сказали,
а це означає не просто цирк у кубі, а цирк просто в стратосфері.
Тобто загалом, звісно, Україна сходить і напевно, дедалі більше сходитиме на задній план.
На другий план.
На другий план. Далі, якщо перемагає Трамп, що цілком може бути,
далі він, він же нам обіцяв, що він за 24 години це все розверне.
Як він розвертатиме, я не знаю, але швидше за все він скаже Зеленському:
знаєш, досить, давай там Кримський міст припиняй бомбити,
Крим віддавай, а там ми можемо ще про щось домовимося.
Але я не знаю, припустімо, Путін усміхається широкою посмішкою
чеширського кота і навіть ще ширше.
Це все може бути, і я, до речі, думаю, що Кремль - до питання, скільки він протримається, -
на це і розраховує та розраховував, коли не вдалося за 5 хвилин захопити Україну,
як ми пам'ятаємо, коли вони збиралися вже бути в Україні, в Києві.
То далі вони й розраховували на нескінченно декадентський Захід,
нестабільну Америку, що ось зараз вона згниє через 5 секунд.
Це, до речі, теж дуже цікаво, бо Хрущов обіцяв загнивання Америки, раніше Сталін обіцяв, потім Брежнєв.
Вона все гниє, але все ніяк. Він на це і розраховував.
І може так вийти, що станеться так.
Що його сидіння на кремлівському троні вже 24 роки,
ще до 2036 року можливе сидіння, і воно пересидить усіх.
У всіх же скільки разів уже змінилися президенти, а він усе сидить.
Так що в цьому сенсі, звісно, в України зараз будуть важкі часи.
У кінцевому рахунку, як я вас зрозумів, образ Росії залишатиметься образом ворога?
І Росії потрібні будуть десять "горбачових", щоб це виправити.
Одна із жахливих речей. Бо ця війна все одно колись закінчиться,
а наступні покоління, на мій погляд, наші діти, будуть ще відпльовуватися
і харкати кров'ю за той жахливий образ, у якому ми, росіяни, постали, в цій війні.
А нічого цього не було б, якби ваш дід не став би ініціатором передачі Криму Україні?
Мій дід і передача - це, загалом, теж формула пропаганди, бо дід насправді нікому нічого не передавав.
Ініціював - я так сказав.
Це не було політичним рішенням.
Це було адміністративне рішення, оскільки радянська влада все робила політично, це було зроблено політично.
Але коли зараз кажуть, що це було протизаконно, проти якого закону?
Вони зібралися, вони про це говорили, вони виступили, вони підписали.
У формулі того закону це було законно.
Від того, що це по-путінськи сьогодні незаконно, це не має жодного значення.
Я думаю, що якби не Крим, то вигадали б щось іще. Абхазію б зробили.
Для Путіна як привід?
Щось би було. Але оскільки Україна з Росією - це завжди якісь певні тертя, то це виявилося зручно.
Але, знаєте, історія не оперує умовними способами,
тому ми вже маємо те, що маємо.
Але в принципі це могло бути… Статуя Володимира цього величезного…
Який біля Кремля стоїть?
Ні, який стоїть не біля Кремля, який стоїть у Києві,
вони могли і через неї теж влаштувати бучу.
Це наш Володимир, віддайте! Українці скажуть - ні. Це не має значення.
Приводи.
Ніно Хрущова, дякую вам.